the
sacrifices you make when you're creating
a brand any creator can relate it's
lonely it can be frightening you can be
scared i'm so proud of myself for
believing in something that i worked so
hard to create it's incredible
my name is alexandra cooper i go by alex
but alexandra because this is forbes i
am 27 and i have a podcast called call
her daddy
call her daddy essentially is
a podcast but also just a brand and a
lifestyle that embodies what maybe you
would talk about with your friends in
your bedroom but maybe too embarrassed
to talk about in public or tweet about
there's so much shame around so many
topics and themes that i was fortunate
to grow up in a household that was
normalized to speak your mind and so i
was like give me the microphone i'll say
it
my dad is in the industry he does sports
production and there was always cameras
in my house and i would pick it up and
point it at my face and be like i need
to be on camera i need to be making
movies and then after college i heard
out like i'm like oh my god what's a
podcast started a podcast and i always
knew i was going to be in the creative
space in some form and it just happened
to be that podcast started to get big
and that's where i landed
[Music]
i think probably the entire business
industry has been
really exciting to learn but also
nerve-wracking like i didn't go to
business school so i'm sitting here and
i know how to be a creative but on the
other side you have to learn how to
manage your business also social media
never turns off and i think that's
something that creators are probably
really struggling with managing how do i
put it down and detach for a minute so i
think i've also learned like more
sometimes is shutting off for a minute
because then i'm going to come back more
refreshed and i'll actually be giving
them quality over quantity
[Music]
spotify is one of the biggest in the
audio space i'm not gonna sit here and
be like yeah you know it's cool like
this is insane that i signed this deal i
think for call her daddy the goal is to
continue to grow
and
maybe like a tv show a book a movie a
tour a christmas album and then i'll
retire at 80.